coronavirus has again hit president
trump's inner circle this time
it's his personal attorney rudy giuliani
who was reportedly admitted yesterday to
georgetown university medical center in
washington
and then last night giuliani tweeted
that he's getting great care
and feeling good wishes now reports from
the white house
how you can say this is unsupported when
there are now tape after tape after tape
rudy giuliani appeared on television
sunday morning
claiming president trump's fight to
overturn the election results
was making progress just hours later the
president revealed that giuliani tested
positive for covin 19. in a tweet he
wished giuliani a speedy recovery
and praised him for working tirelessly
exposing what he described
as the most corrupt election by far in
the history of the usa
a claim that mr trump continues to
peddle even though it is
not true giuliani's diagnosis follows
weeks of traveling across the country to
contest the november results through
courts last week he spoke in arizona
georgia and
michigan often without covering his face
i don't want you to do this if you feel
uncomfortable
but would you be comfortable taking a
mask off so that people could hear you
more clearly can you hear me now last
tuesday the arizona republican party
tweeted out this picture of giuliani
posing with
several lawmakers all without masks
the state's legislature announced sunday
it would close for a week
out of an abundance of caution for
recent cases and concerns relating to
covet 19.
in a statement the trump campaign legal
team says giuliani did not
experience any symptoms or test positive
within 48 hours
of returning from his trip he was most
recently in georgia on thursday
as for their efforts to fight the
outcome of the election a campaign
attorney says giuliani
getting the virus will not impact their
work and that they
will press on gail all right we should
thank you very much